when I was growing up I got caught up in
the Bobby Fischer boom
. end of story and I would go to a
coffee shop at the University of
Washington in Seattle and everybody had
the newspaper and they were playing over
the Bobby Fischer game and we would just
do analysis nobody was playing blitz
what was really really cool as if they
had an adjournment okay then it was sort
of like you know everybody wants to know
who's better who's winning
stop that who's better who's winning and
these sessions were so much fun they
were free for all this analysis even
though I was a very very weak player
everybody had an opinion and I was
listening to all of these opinions and
then I would say well I'm with these
guys you know they're the strongest
players in the group I'm going to go
with their choice and recently of course
there was the candidates the candidates
tournament being such an important event
in the entire cycle it determines the
Challenger as we know fidei has
announced that in November of this year
in New York City which is very cool
they're going to try to organize the
event there it came down to these two
players Sergey karyakin was white from
Russia versus Fabiana Caruana
black from the United States and if
Javie onnot was to win the game you know
how cool he American representative wow
it would just have been a Hollywood
script writers dream match up the game
is terribly marred what I mean is
both players entering the game had the
same number of points that is to say
they were equal they were tied for first
the problem was the tie breakers and and
the first tie break makes perfect sense
to me don't get me wrong the first
hybrid the players do in their
head-to-head match in the first cycle
this is a double round-robin in the
first cycle they they drew with one
another if this game was a draw then you
would have to go to the next tie break
the second tie break to my mind which
would have been the most sensible would
have just been a playoff just have them
play some rapid games and blitz and an
Armageddon whatnot and get a result over
the board the second tie break was who
has the most number of wins at first it
sounds very compelling if somebody won
more games than the other guy let him be
the tiebreaker but in this case we'll
understand that it wasn't the tie
breaker who had the most wins it was a
tiebreaker of who had the most losses
what does it what do I mean at this
point in the tournament both players had
what we call plus two that is to say
they had won two more games than they
had lost in the case of Fabiano he had
won two games but had been undefeated
Sergey karyakin had won three games but
he had one loss so you reward the number
of wins or the number of losses okay
unfortunately for Fabiano it meant
because of the tiebreaker he was in a
situation he had to win his black that
means he has got to take some excessive
risks the openings to unbalance the
position and for the opening it's funny
that I really for he chose a Sicilian
the problem with a large number of
Sicilians is that in some very very very
sharp lines white has been
forcing draws he can play like in the
poison pond there's a number of lines
that would end in a three move
repetition so Fabiano not only has to
choose an opening or a defense that's
going to unbalance the game and give him
winning chances he also can't play the
most sharpest variations because they
tend to be drawn all right so what he
chooses is what we would call the
classical Sicilian what I call the
classical Sicilian and it also has the
four-night Sicilian so the four Knights
are brought out right away and it's
actually a very good choice because
White's path to getting an advantage
against this specific move order is
rather narrow this move Bishop g5 what
was played is literally in my database a
four to one favorite like this move
Bishop g5 is played four times as much
as the alternative move which is Bishop
c4 okay let me see Bishop c4 this has
been played 25% of the time versus
Bishop g5 and the main line against
Bishop c4 goes like this and the players
arrive at what is called a seven ingen
Sicilian where these two pawns are on e6
and d6 and this bishop on c4 looks a
little bit misplaced like why did he put
his bishop on c4 isn't it like a
tactical target to this knight moving
and so forth practice has shown that
black has very good results from this
position and therefore we see the move
Bishop g5 e six Queen d2 and these moves
have been played literally for the last
60 odd years
and the line is called the Richter
rouser two guys Richter was playing it
rouser played it too so they both shared
the name of the defense the Richter
browser now h7 h6 is a little bit of a
sideline move the main move is b5 and
the question is is does black need this
pawn on h6 or is it better placed on h7
that's the question it's not easy as it
turns out in the game the both players
transpose directly into the rouser so
it's not that important there is one
detail that is important and that is
this detail Knight takes e4 this gives
the variation a little bit of
Independence in other words h6 could
lead to this capture Knight takes e4 in
a first sight that looks like a really
good move the knight is pinned to the
queen by the bishop but when the knight
moved it attack White's Queen and this
capture leads to one of the most
confounding positions that you're likely
to see the most important move is Queen
e1 if white captures this Knight then
Queen takes Knight takes Bishop takes
Knight takes Bishop takes Queen takes
Queen e7 or rook d8 blacks got no
problems at all okay so the best move is
Queen e1 Queen e1 protects the bishop
sorry I apologize let me just put one
other move in here in case of Bishop
takes d8 taking the Queen
well after Knight takes Queen no problem
there's just been a trade if you take
the knight he takes your bishop if you
move your bishop away this night we'll
take this bishop and black will emerge a
pawn to the good so the main move is
Queen e1 and this is a very well known
trap that after Knight f6 because the
bishop is protected the knight is
attacked Knight f6 Knight f5 a very
strange position starts to emerge this
Knight on f5 can't be captured because
of course it's in a pin and the knight
is threatening to capture the pawn on d6
so let's imagine that the Queen goes to
b8 and the King goes to b1 and I write
in my comments it's a rather amusing
position because in this position with
all the pieces on the board with black
being a pawn to the good it's very hard
to make a positive suggestion for black
what can black move he can't move his
dark squared Bishop so that he could
Castle because that would hang the pawn
on g7 he can't move his pawn to d5
because after Bishop takes there would
be Knight takes d5 and white will win
back his pawn so the theory has said
that this position is actually very bad
for black and that is why black does not
capture what appears to be a free pawn
it's a it took some while to develop
that but there you have it b5 these are
the standard moves now G takes f6 Bishop
takes f6
why not Queen takes f6 why did he
recapture with the pawn on f6 well one
of the things that we can see in the
position is that White Queen and rook
are in a very nice battery along the D
file and that Y can take advantage of
this battery by playing the movie v in
order to open up the position after D
takes e5 Knight takes b5 there's a very
very big threat in the position Queen
takes d7 check and mate as well as
Knight to c7 for King the king and the
rook Queen goes back takes takes takes
now in this position it doesn't look
that tragic for black he's not to add
down material okay his king is still a
little bit stuck but not so bad until we
start to realize that if we could play
the move Knight b5 it would simply be
awesome so let's take care but take that
pawn off the board rook takes a 695 and
this is a very well known position which
is just considered much much better for
white okay which is why they capture on
f6 with the pawn okay all of these moves
are very standard in at the elite level
these guys just bang out those moves
f5 all very well-known Queen b6 so you
could say that the players are playing
standard moves this move F takes c6
however is less standard the most common
move in this position is Knight takes c6
Queen takes c6 Bishop d3
and basically white keeps the tension of
these
pawns on f7 and f5 Sergei however he
wanted to clarify the position and I
don't necessarily think that he made a
bad decision only I think that it's
easier for black to play the position
without the double pawns okay so maybe a
little score for Fabiano at this point
nothing special all of these moves are
very standard and now remember when I
was saying does the pawn belong on h7 or
h6 in this case a fabbi played the move
h5 with a very clear and evil intention
he wants to develop his Bishop on f8 to
h6 and to pin the Queen to the king so
king b1 and from White's point of view
his opening is completed his rooks are
connected from blacks point of view his
rooks aren't connected so he needs still
a few moves to get out of the opening
black faces a very very severe question
and it's not easily answered the
question is where are you going to put
your king okay you're probably not going
to Castle short and okay you could
Castle long but then your pawn shield on
the Queen side is already advanced and
it's not going to be a bed of roses for
the King on the King side it's more
likely your king is going to be stuck in
the center and the King is likely to
step up to the e7 plate which is fine
that's a nice fortification of pawns
that the King in the center is really
always open to attacks the attacks can
come
either flanks or through the center so
it's a very dangerous double-edged
position that Fabiano has embraced
because of the circumstance he has to
win with black I don't like the move h5o
pardon me I I didn't like the movie for
before to my mind was the wrong move I
think
Fabiano for better or for worse should
have played castles rook hf1 Bishop e7
completing his development connecting
the rooks I'm not saying that he's much
worse or white is better or any of that
stuff I'm saying this was just simply a
necessary line for black to play now if
you don't like this position we'll find
another defense but what he played in
the game was not good and it was very
clear that after this move before Knight
back Queen c5 this was a moment that
Sergei missed that he could really
really taken a huge initiative maybe
just an awesome advantage he actually
played in the game work hf1 missing his
opportunity so first opportunity for
White was this very cool move e5 ok it's
like one of those moves like when you
first see it you go is that possible I
mean black is defending the e Phi square
not once twice but thrice now it's very
easy to refute one capture let's go
let's refute them all D takes e5 is over
instantly check we've seen this one
before there's that battery check and
mate
the other recapture Queen takes
five walks into rook at each rook h2e
one Bishop h6 queen takes b4 king 794
and the amazing part is that this is a
variation that had been played between
two top grandmasters pranced setter and
casual social with grandmaster from
croatia european champion has played
this position and lost several games
hence the variation is known as the
kosher suicide defense I kid you not
can you spot the winning continuation
for white
and I'll shout out at once
very good very good
Knight f5 check as then suggested takes
and rook e1 and it's just not nice the
Queen the exposed black King gives white
a winning advantage so you can't play
Queen takes e5 the only other move you
have in the position is F takes e5 now
the line goes Queen g5 and you're
threatening made on the spot bishop g6
is made the only move is Bishop e7 Queen
g7 you now you can't castle because the
bishop on e7 is unprotected the only
move is rook f8 rook f1 trade trade now
you're threatening Queen g8 mate the
only move is Bishop c6 rook f7 the only
move is d5 Bishop g6 threatening
discovered attack King d7 and Queen
takes e5 now after this recapture White
has regained his pawn and he's got a
really nice grip on the position you can
see that ideas like Knight d4 is in the
air even ideas like Bishop takes h5
Bishop g4 winning material black is in
deep trouble which means we have to find
where black went wrong earlier yeah and
it might be that that move h6 if this
pawn it remained on h7 this whole attack
would not have worked alright after
Queen c5 Sergei played rook hf1 Bishop
h6 Queen e1 a5 and we reach the first in
a very very fascinating and crucial game
in the game Sergei has played the move
b2 b3 and
I must say this moved b-two b-three if
you're anything like me confuse the hell
out of me I didn't understand that move
when it first appeared on the board at
all the question I would have for
yourselves is why Sergey didn't capture
the pawn on f6 rook takes f6 winning
wins upon I mean I'm an old pawn grub or
give me a pawn I feeling good
why didn't Sergei take this pawn what do
you think what was he afraid
precisely right precisely right
so as the gentleman was saying big
problems with the long dark diagonal
Queen e5 rook f3 Bishop g7 and you can
see instantly that woo-hoo-hoo-hoo
you may want to avoid letting that black
queen and that black Bishop line up for
a battery against b2 but you just have
to go and move or to deeper for the
moment white is still upon ahead blacks
King still isn't you know off the off
the highway and if you continue the line
for example a for Queen g3 sorry I
wanted to do something else I apologize
no this was right BC three Shack King d8
Knight c3 a3 rook f7 Bishop h6 this is a
crazy double edge position I mean it's a
mess and again considering that all that
Sergei needed was a draw we can imagine
why he shied away from taking the pawn
on f6 okay now we understand why he
wasn't so greedy like myself but why did
he play the move b3 what's up with that
doesn't that move isn't that kind of
counterintuitive doesn't that just
weaken a lot of dark squares and on a
good day we can imagine the Queen
shifting over the bishop and having the
pawn on b2 seems to be more helpful for
white than for black so why did he
played the movie 3 what was White's
intention
mmm not so easy is it
let's say I had it tough as well
fortunately for me a sergei cleared my
cobwebs when after rook g8 g3 King e7 he
played the move Bishop c4 now though I
suddenly got it okay so the bishop
stepped up to the square c4
so he could open up the rook but also
his Knight is now angling for ideas like
Knight to d4 to f5 with a discovered
check maybe against the king and also
simply eyeballing this pawn on d6 so the
position has become double-edged but at
this exact moment funnily enough for me
I actually favored Fabiano's position in
other words kudos to him he got a
position where look this is not an easy
draw for white why he's going to have to
play some really fine moves too to
continue the game I really like this
move Bishop e3 as well it basically it
shuts in the night so that the knight
can't jump to d4 and it just plunks the
bishop down in the middle of the board
the bishop on h6 was a little offside on
a good day we could imagine that this
bishop may even end up on the score 5
and wouldn't that be a wonderful thing
okay rook f3 rook g4 a plain old honoré
counter-attack what can you say if the
bishop now on c4 no longer defends the
pawn on e4
well let's attack it okay Knight f4 elk
pardon me Queen f1 rook f8 9 f 4 so now
we get to really what I felt was
another absolutely absolutely critical
moment you can see that this has been a
fantastic game a battle of ideas white
blacks King is in the middle of the
board but he's got those three pawns
protecting his King White's King is safe
on the flank but on the other hand
blacks influence in the center means
that with the active King you can easily
go into an endgame because blacks King
might end up being more active than your
King furthermore these two pawns while
may not really look at or feel it at the
moment the two pawns are doing a great
job at keeping this majority in check
yeah so there was a lot of things I
liked about blacks position
Fabiana made a move that really stuck in
my craw I just thought that that move
was wrong on all kinds of levels never
forget that chess is a fight between
human beings and human beings have
emotions there's no doubt that Fabiana
wanted to play in fact he has played for
it to move Bishop d4 okay because you
know bang you know killing the black
killing the white King on the dark
squares and on a good day we could
imagine this bishop dropping back and
the Queen coming here and it's all she
wrote Fabiano in the postgame interview
he said that he had wanted to play
Bishop d4 but he had rejected it because
of this very forcing variation he
reached this position and he found
himself to be uncomfortable and he
right the computer engine agrees that
White has an advantage but again it's
not about being right or wrong it's
about what's going to make your opponent
unhappy and in this position I really
felt very strongly that that he needed
that is to say Fabiano needed to analyze
deeper I looked at this position for
over an hour with my colleagues
Grandmaster Maurice Ashley Alejandro
Ramirez and Eric Hansen and the line
would have continued rook takes e4 this
is exactly the position that Fabiana
reached in his post game a commentary
and he had to see this move f5 and this
move f5 is really a kind of a cool move
first of all it defends the rook but
secondly it sets up the possibility for
the bishop retreating and the Queen to
slide over woo the line would continue
Knight g6 check sorry
where's my line knight g6 check rook
takes g6 H takes g6 and then the line I
was looking at was Bishop e8 so the idea
from blacks point of view is very clear
he wants to take this pawn with his
bishop or drop over here with his rook
then he wants to move this bishop out of
the way so he can play either d5 and
queenie e5 and even though he's an
exchange down I mean it's I mean I were
white I'd be you know scared I'd be
scared that that Bishop and Queen would
ever get on the battery anyway
unfortunately or fortunately depending
upon your point of view
Fabiano did play in fact the computers
recommended move Bishop takes f4 and
it's a good move there's nothing wrong
with that move I'm just saying I think
that Bishop d4 would have really put the
hurt on Sergei rook takes f4 this is
where Fabiana definitely gets on the
wrong track again I prefer blacks
position I really really like that these
guys on a five and B four are working
very well against these guides for the
moment blacks King looks very safe and
on a good day we can imagine that if
this rook is traded on g4 and the pawn
is recaptured that pawn on g4 would
freeze another two so the line would
continue for black Bishop c6 okay this
is not the move that Fabiano played
Fabiana played a bad move and the line
would have continued Bishop c6 Queen d3
rook on f8 to g8 and I just prefer
blacks position okay I think on a good
day his intentions are very clear he
wants to play Queen e5 and he wants to
play Bishop takes e4 again if blacks
King remains let's say sheltered there's
no massive attacks coming his way in an
end game black will have an advantage in
the center what Fabiana did instead is
he played take take he played the move a
four again at first sight I can't blame
him for plentiful choosing this move
except that in rousers this pawn on b4
is known to be weak and the Queen gets
anchored
to the defense of the pawn and it's much
better that the Queen have a can freely
play the e5 a4 actually helped white
because after takes takes we can see
that there's Bishop and we'll see that
in a moment can drop back to b3 whereas
actually protecting the King really
really well let's see how the game
continued Queen d3 Bishop c6 Bishop b3
rook g5 and another key critical moment
it doesn't look it
blacks King looks a little bit safe
until you start to visualize that if
this pawn were gone there'd be ideas of
check the rook could switch over to c4
and it wasn't too long before this very
thematic pawn break in the center 'if
I've was played at this point I really
thought that fabulous honest chances of
winning had really gone down because
blacks king is suddenly vulnerable on
two attacks on both Flynt from both
lengths the h7 and from the Queen site
as we'll see rook switches across very
nicely attacks the Queen now you've got
to pay attention to this pawn on d6
rook d5 now if you trade Queens then
black is very happy so white drop back
with his queen black with his rook
switched over to h4
unfortunately for Fabiano at this point
the game has been so complex he was
getting into time trouble being a very
little time on his clock to think and he
had to hurry his moves in a position
which is just really really complex he
played the move rookie five and I really
think that this was a mistake
at this point I think it would have been
much easier for him to take some pieces
off the board for crying out loud rook
takes EA queen takes a eight it's not
that this pawn is so important it's
really about the safety of the King so
for example if you just imagine the move
for example like d5 just for argument's
sake rook takes h5 you could imagine
that after Bishop back here and Bishop
here keep your King safe instead Fabiana
I this was a calculating mistake that he
had prepared a long time in advance and
you know again it was very very awkward
and and hidden but he saw this
remarkable move Bishop g4 okay what his
idea was is he wants to play the move d5
and then bring his bishop back to e4 and
defend his king in this way with the
pawn on d5 and the bishop on e4 then
these ideas of rook h7 check are no
longer available rook to d4 attacking
the pawn on went to d5 Queen here and
now white is going to win his pawn back
with this double attack
of rook takes b4 or queen takes g2 Val
biana had seen this for a long long time
ago and he played the move rookie 4
which looks really really good
because you can't take the bishop if you
take the bishop you'll end up losing an
exchange sweet black is winning and if
you take the rook then after Bishop
takes blacks upon up and you're not
winning either this one or this one for
the moment black is better so this is
the position that Fabiana had been
playing for a few moves moves ago got to
this position and suddenly BAM
oh dear oh dear
that uncorked that just opened up the
floodgates against White's King it was a
devastating rook sacrifice and all of
the grandmasters we looked at each other
and our faces went oh you Daisy okay you
have to capture and after Queen takes
Fabiana thought that would this move
Queen c7 defending the d7 square he's
got it all under control it was this
quiet move that he had either a
underestimated or B simply missed with
this quiet move Queen f5 White's just
threatening Queen h7 check and this
simply no defense to this devastating
threat the King is stuck in the center
and it doesn't have adequate defenders
in the game fab you tried rook f7 he
could have also tried another move that
wouldn't have saved him Queen c6 because
of after Queen c6 check check if Sergei
wants a perpetual check a draw gives him
the the the challengers
but in fact Bishop d5 would win the game
as well because the next move is check
and you're going to capture this rook on
e4 so you'll win back the rook and
blacks King is still in a world of hurt
in the game fabbi tried rook f7 but
there's just no - no play it's just over
check King here and here he resigned the
point is if the bishop is captured it's
made in checkmate in two moves ah sigh
and with this loss American chess all
cried our loss was Russia's gain because
I can imagine all of these
schoolchildren and Russia just like
cheering as the hero Sergei karyakin
was man of the hour remember this one
I'll close the lecture with a wonderful
quote of Michael tall michael tall in
1961 the World Championship against
Mikhail Botvinnik and he did it by doing
everything wrong in chess he violated
all the principles and he sacrificed and
he just constantly hyper-aggressive he
beat the scientific Michael ba Vinick a
year later in the 1961 return match
Michael bud Vinick won and they asked
tall well how did he feel after losing
the return match and tall said well I
don't feel very good but all the Soviet
schoolchildren are very happy because
now they can go back to studying how to
protect their pawns and pieces instead
of having to learn how to sacrifice them
we will see what Sergei karyakin
brings to the World Championship match
which will be again in November it's
slated for November their individual
scores against one another
pretty extraordinary they have drawn 15
times that's a lot of draws Sergei has
won one time but he has lost three times
so they both tasted each other's blood
but that 15 draws tells me that this is
going to be a very very competitive game
on paper of course Magnus is the
favorite is the rating higher rating
Magnus is also a favorite for another
reason Magnus has had two experiences in
World Championship matches that World
Championship experience and knowing what
it needs to win is huge and for Sergei
this will be his first chance in the
World Championship it's interesting that
you could say that this match was
predicted a decade ago why
Sergei karyakin was the youngest Grand
Master in in the history of chess he was
12 years old when he got the Grandmaster
title at 12 years old when he got the
Grandmaster title everybody looked at
him and said you're going to be world
champion so this match has been one
that's foretold it will be very
interesting
you